creator my friend Rod Fergusson
Thanks so good morning everybody in
addition to showing off all that HTR
goodness the new Xbox one S delivers
gears for will also be one of the first
titles in the new Xbox program Xbox play
anywhere this icon means when you buy
the game digitally you get to own it and
play it on both Xbox one and Windows 10
PC that's with your progress and your
achievements saved on Xbox Live and
shared across both platforms all at no
additional cost to you and beyond that
when gears 4 is released on both
platforms this October every co-op mode
in the game will support cross play so
players on Xbox one and Windows 10 can
play together through the co-op campaign
co-op multiplayer and yes even the
all-new horde mode now to help me
demonstrate the co-op campaign I'd like
to introduce Gears for costar and my
friend the voice of Kate Laura Bailey
hi Laura hello Ron I am so excited to
show off the campaign in this demo
Kate's mother Reina has been abducted by
a monstrous new threat the swarm and
it's up to our team to save her before
it's too late so let's take a look Xbox
one and Windows 10 exclusive
just keep coming yeah and that wavelet
is getting worse I say we wait it out
you can't not if we're gonna save Rena
okay ready or not let's get back out
there
take cover
you are done
now we get across
No
okay help out of that sorry
all right
I can't believe that worked come on
let's go
doesn't work
you look like you pick me up
Thanks help me with this
right out of the store into this water
really
that second
don't get worse
get the nest
corner of connected rain
broadcast this we're getting my mother
back then we're burning her
welcome home James